and she should Serena Williams is
winning again the tennis star triumphed
yesterday at the ASB Classic in New
Zealand it's her first tournament win in
three years and her first since the
birth of her two-year-old daughter
Olympia vladimir duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn is here vlad this
was a long time coming but it sure was
sweet
good morning Anthony yes this victory
was very sweet indeed and she made it
look easy winning in straight sets
against a tough opponent New York native
Jessica Pegula but to hold that trophy
Williams had to fight some personal
battles as well with that Serena
Williams was back on top winning her
73rd singles how does it feel it feels
good it's been a long time I think you
could see the relief of my face
the 38 year old Williams beat 25 year
old rising star Jessica Pegula in two
sets lasting upwards of two hours and 20
minutes Euro 2020 is P women's singles
champion Serena Williams spoke of her
frustrations prior to Sunday's win zone
a few times play pretty well in New York
the challenges haven't just been on the
court
her daughter's birth was complicated
with Williams experiencing blood clots
forcing her to undergo multiple
surgeries in 2018
she wrote of her struggles with
postpartum depression in an Instagram
post she said mostly I felt like I was
not a good mom it's totally normal to
feel like I'm not doing enough for my
baby and I just said it's really cool to
see your daughter out here fine today
because she looked beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
Williams is donating Sunday's prize of
43,000 dollars to help victims of the
Australian bushfires
this win in New Zealand is the lead-up
to Serena's next big match the
Australian Open in Melbourne and so this
is exactly what I needed
going into Melbourne and it's it's good
it's really good she has left a force to
be reckoned with this week you might
remember Olympia's birth sparked a rule
change for the Women's Tennis
Association for players returning from
pregnancy Williams had faced criticism
at the French Open for wearing tighter
clothing designed to help her muscles
recover after the backlash the WTA
cleared the way for leggings and
compression shorts for all women three
years after her so happy for her and it
was great to see her daughter I'm very
happy wearing that championship what do
you call it like a shawl there yeah good
you weren't here last second but but
Tara's daughters okay we because we
forgot to say her daughter's okay so
symptom that she had me - yeah the way
to see you again bladder
you